mountains beyond mountains is pulitzer
prize-winning author tracy Kidder's
latest work next the subject of the
biography dr. Paul Farmer joins mr.
Kidder to discuss his efforts at
treating communicable diseases among the
poor this program is just over an hour
I'm gonna start I don't think it's
necessary with this audience to
introduce Paul Farmer or give you his CV
I will say though going I will give you
just a little bit before he became
important he was he grew up in the on a
bus with his five siblings and his mom
and dad and then on a boat which was
more than a bayous north of Tampa his
father his mother is a notably sweet and
an Electra gifted woman who for a long
time worked at a winn-dixie supermarket
in Florida his father was a great big
guy ferociously competitive athlete
nicknamed elbows by people who played
basketball with him and who decided his
family was going to live on this boat
and I don't know what that has to do
with the trajectory of Paul's career
exactly I don't think he does either but
it's it's an interesting fact about his
life he went on as you know from there
to Duke and from there to Harvard in
takács simultaneously that's the thing
that I find most interesting in this
back story of Paul's which is that while
he was getting his PhD in anthropology
and his MD he was also beginning to
build this remarkable healthcare system
and one of the two poorest parts of the
poorest country in the Western
Hemisphere and and I before we get to
the fun here I just want to say that in
my opinion I think manured zuv Jim Kim
polls close associate these I'm
borrowing his words he I think correctly
calls Emilio Sun pay a laboratory for
the
world and I think it's more and more
clear that it is in fact we have an
example right here in Boston a
technology transfer from Haiti to Boston
of a dot program called pact which is
also run by Partners in Health which
treats a underserved HIV patients and
has is now using the technique that was
pretty much pioneered in Kosh to very
good effect I'm told um this was billed
as a conversation between me and Paul
the problem with that is of course that
you never know if we're gonna be able to
produce a good one for you so I thought
at least start with one that lies
somewhere back in the past in which I've
committed to fight the promise that we
don't like having conversations how is
that I thought we did you mean I the
time I wasn't going to read that in that
conversation but maybe I should this is
this is this is from somewhere deep in
my book and we're at we're in an airport
again and I thought this was a pretty
good conversation we got to the airport
early for once and went to a cafe for
breakfast
okay farmers said when we found a table
time to get to work he pulled out his
most recent watt list Watts brought his
Creole per box and he makes these lists
of the chores to do there's those are
called watts only about two-thirds of
the little boxes have been checked this
is shameful he stared at the sheets of
paper all these bots were supposed to be
done before we left Cuba among them was
a dual boîte one that consisted of two
chores if he completed either he'd get
to check the box
the dual blood commanded me of either to
buy new underwear or to finish a letter
I I didn't get the underwear so this was
a letter he had started during a hike
we'd taken back in Haiti
he pulled the unfinished page from his
briefcase it had a grease stain on it
from some some article of v food group
he'd eaten on the hike it seems fitting
to write to you as I sit in the middle
of the Haitian countryside the letter
began he bent over it
writing on is this what transfer or blot
cheating I asked depends on whether or
not you have an H of G for the endeavor
he said without looking up an H of G was
short for a hermeneutic of generosity
which he had defined once for me in an
email
I have a hermeneutic of generosity for
you because I know you're a good guy
therefore I will interpret what you say
and do in a favorable light seems like
I'm the one who should hope for as much
from you I have counted scores of terms
like that one in his lexicon which was
also the lexicon of PIH gym at Ophelia
had invented some and some came from the
Brigham but most were farmers or his
families one time his brother Jeff the
wrestler sent him a card in which he
misspelled the word Haitians he spent it
he spelt it had Ian's
so in PIH lingo Haitians were had Ian's
or simply hats and their country was had
land
the French were franchisee their tongue
franchisee language and Russians were
Rooskies a chatterjee was a person of
East Indian descent there were a few and
PIH who talked a lot farmer referred to
himself as white trash he had an old
photo to prove it his extended family
had a picnic
around a couch outdoors Phillips Academy
sorry that picture was actually stolen
from me in Spain and someone mailed it
back from Spain so the whole wallet was
just goes to show you my grandmother
around the couch I know I'm not supposed
to interrupt you no no please underwear
boxes in front of hundreds of people I
think is a bit speaking of couches
that's one of my favorite former lines I
said to your mother once that there were
no couch potatoes in your family and she
said no couch
sorry the man who railed about the
plight of impoverished women everywhere
would in private poking fun employed
terms like chicks I don't care about any
Harvard okay this is Longfellow hall
that was a I should have cut that I'm
sorry I don't care about any of that
stuff he told me once just the one thing
in polite terms used intramural e we're
met his philosophical rebukes to the
misplaced preoccupations of those who
believed in identity politics in the
idea that all members of an oppressed
minority were equally oppressed which
all too conveniently obscured the fact
that there were real differences in the
shafted Ness also sometimes called the
degrees of hos admits that people of the
same race or gender suffered all
suffering isn't equal was an article of
the PIH faith generated in reaction to
the many times when they had tried to
raise money and instead had been offered
lectures about the universality of
suffering or simply lines like the rich
have problems too farmer once taught a
course of course at Harvard called
varieties of human suffering was a real
winner to well-attended when people get
around Paul they start talking like Paul
his old friend from medical school the
writer Ethan Canin said he's such a word
gymnast there was an obvious utility and
the brevity of terms like H of G for a
mind moving fast and for people trying
to keep up when for instance T BMI
transnational bureaucrats managing
inequality
well they exist you have to everywhere
produce clever arguments also known as
well-formed stool against treating MDR
AIDS one could simply say love ID and be
completely understood oh dear this is
explained earlier in the book that's
that's just too hard to explain but it
means basically you should when in doubt
you treat ID says treat I D stands for
infectious disease maybe you should
everyone at PIH knew that DQ stood for
drama queen and a DQ proposal meant an
emotional appeal we could use a DQ quote
here and a generic inequality of
outcomes over here I once heard farmers
say to a young assistant working with
him on a speech she's in medical school
at Harvard now geek flowers was the
completed research that PIH was
presented to Farmer or Kim and skull but
was short for scholarly buttressing
which meant that every statement of fact
farmer made in a paper had to be
verified as coming from some
authoritative source he's neurotic about
having it all perfect said a medical
student who did a lot of school but for
farmer not because he's anal but because
when you're doing these things for the
poor amidst arguments that it's not
cost-effective to treat them you have to
be perfect or you'll be picked apart
lugar was luggage Coutu meant customs to
commit a 7-3 was to use seven words
where three would do and a 99/100 was
quitting on a nearly completed job
nothing pisses me off like a 99/100
farmer would say VIH errs often said
thank you to people who had done
something for a third party for anyone
who belonged to the multitudinous group
known variously as the indigent sick
sick the shafted and the poor the last
being the term of choice in PIH because
as farmer would say it was the term that
most Haitians used to describe
themselves you could hang around the
inner circle of PIH for a long time
without understanding what the rules
were and feeling excluded and the more
left out you felt the more you suspect
that you were being told you weren't as
good as they were even as you've
suspected that your irritation proved
to me the inner circle of PIH seemed
like a club or even like a family which
was deeply opposed to the concept of
insiders and outsiders and yet equipped
with its own special bylaws and language
say that the farmer and he'd reply if so
it's surely the most inclusive damn club
in the world
being full of people with AIDS wls
galore from distance church ladies lots
of patients and it's a club that grows
and never shrinks and farmer had a way
of creating a club that consisted just
of him and you back in Haiti he had
established a piece of private language
for our month of travel discussing
malaria with me he'd explained there
were four types only one of which
falciparum was often fatal so which one
do you suppose Haiti has he asked then
he added but it's not drug resistant the
way it is in Africa he smiled and then
adapting his favorite line from the
movie Caddyshack he said so we got that
going for us then he pointed at me and I
soon learned this meant I was supposed
to utter the next line in the movie
which is nice after I got the hang of
this call in response I enjoyed it and I
must confess I felt a certain pleasure
now at the airport cafe and knowing what
he meant by an H of G he went on writing
his letter I looked around the airport
Shaul de Gaulle has an angular steel and
glass simplicity which struck me just
then as frightening Li complex which
made me feel projected into a future I
didn't understand I thought of its
duty-free shop where one could buy
first-class pate confit I can't
pronounce this do I go on crew wines you
started that letter on a hike in rural
Haiti I mused aloud thinking now of
those arid Highlands of medieval peasant
huts
donkey ambulances it seems like another
world farmer looked up smiling and Anna
chirpy sounding voice he said but that
feeling has the disadvantage of being he
paused the beat
wrong well i retorted it depends on how
you look at it no it doesn't he replied
in a very pleasant voice the polite
thing to say would be you're right it's
a parallel universe there really is no
relation between the massive
accumulation of wealth in one part of
the world and abject misery and another
he looked at me he'd made me laugh you
know I'm being funny about something
serious he said
one time I listened to him give a talk
on HIV to a class at the Harvard School
of Public Health and in the midst of
reciting data he mentioned the Haitian
phrase looking for life destroying life
then he explained it's an expression
Haitians use if a poor woman selling
mangos falls off a truck and dies very
early in your time in Haiti his time in
Haiti he he and Ophelia Dahl came upon
that woman who'd fallen off the truck
mango the mango woman died just as many
years before I felt as if for that 20 I
felt as if for that moment I could see a
little way into his mind it seemed like
a place of hyper-connectivity at moments
like that I thought that what he wanted
was to erase both time and geography
connecting all parts of his life and
tying them instrumentally to a world in
which he saw intimate inescapable
connections between the gleaming
corporate offices of Paris and New York
and a legless man lying in the mud floor
of a hut and the remotest part of remote
Haiti of all the world's errors he
seemed to feel the most fundamental was
the erasing of people the hiding away of
suffering my big struggle is how people
can not care a race not remember I had
wondered if there was room in his
philosophy for anyone but the world's
poor and people who campaigned on behalf
of the poor one day on an airplane he
confided to me that he thought of all
our fellow fellow passengers as patients
and attendants voice had said over the
intercom is there a doctor on board he'd
gotten up at once and ministered to a
middle-aged evidently middle-class
American man who as it turned out wasn't
having a heart attack back in his seat
afterward farmer said this happened to
him about once in every 18 flights I had
the impression that he wouldn't have
minded if it happened every flight
embracing a continuity and
interconnectedness that excluded no one
seemed like another of farmers peculiar
liberties it came with a lot of burdens
of course but it also freed him from the
efforts that many people make to find
refuge and distinction from their pasts
and from the mass of their fellow human
beings maybe we should talk about this
now or something else guy knows how to
write but I really do have a plan
for getting back at him revenge first I
would like to say this feels like a
place of hyper-connectivity this room
because I know so many of you and so
many our friends and supporters of
Partners in Health I also have a guest
up from Haiti our pharmacists over a
Sukkah font II can't babe when when you
expect to a bit me a video don't I
remember
yeah actually sober appears as the
pharmacist on a trip to visit a patient
but I'll get that act of that in a
minute
so visit to our country and and and it
it's been he's staying with with me some
people I wrote to Tracy a note just
today I don't think he's gotten him
because his commuter has a virus which
he were few were careful he would not
have but I wrote him a note today saying
that recently in Elliott house where I
lived there's been epic a me Allah gist
have noted a certain spike in the
presence of Haitians in that house since
you were a student there but that some
people from Harvard School of Public
Health were going to come and study the
private the unusual prevalence of
Haitians in Elliott house now he laughs
at my jokes and that was the whole trip
you see never let anyone trip travel
with you that long first of all they
inevitably get tired of you they get
tired of your humor and you know they or
they complain about the way you travel
and then you know if you're traveling
with a writer that then they write about
it and it's and it's it's it's really
it's burdensome I'll tell you but I've
decided that I'm going to be writing a
number of books myself
I've just finished one called travels
with Tracy and I have two chapters on
you know his travel idiosyncrasies I
think some in this room who will be
familiar with them one is you're not
allowed to accept late boarding passes
that's like a whole chapter another is
you can only land on paved runways which
you know is inconvenient in some of the
places I worked some of them are made of
grass and they have goats on them others
have seashells that was a good one
Jeremy in southern Haiti and there's I
have a chapter on that and then I have
the latter third of the book you know
the of the book travels with Tracy is is
about his GI system so there's a you
know there is and I hope I don't offend
anyone by saying that there is there's a
chapter on stool consistency but that's
just Volume one of my new series you
know III let me just say I went to my
first conference of writers Sun Valley
Writers Conference and I don't know why
they didn't invite me before I had
published just as many books as Tracy
had and now I have no proof that anyone
other than my mother ever read them but
in terms of number we were dead even and
so I went to my first Writers Conference
they gave me a pen see I've got proof
Sun Belt Sun Valley Writers Conference
this is the pen and and their idea of
humor okay this is this friend of mine
who went to Harvard Medical School was a
good friend of mine he's no longer a
friend of mine have decided because he
thought the funny you know people would
say oh when's your book coming out to me
I said it came out in April just like
that you know get mine April like come
on you want a piece of me I got a book
too and so the name of that book was
pathologists of power and as a retort
because you know that what they really
mean is when to Tracy's book come out
and when is Tracy's book coming out
which you know for another writer I mean
it's not really what you want to hear
right it's true and so I said it came
out in April and then gave them a
combative look and but the the joke in
response was oh yeah when's it coming
out in paper and then they all cracked
up like that was hilarious
but that a book of mine would be in
paper I would like Harvard bookstore to
stand up for us nerdy academic authors
who occasionally do make it into paper
anyway I can't complain about Harvard
bookstore they're giving partes and
helped money but anyway volume two of my
series on Tracy is called Cry the
Beloved Tracy and that book which isn't
done yet I'm about halfway through
that's about making home visits in with
Tracy in Haiti yeah let me tell you at
least he had you know the humility to
put one of these in his book that one
right there which I noticed is the only
book up for sale outside but anyway so
that's the Prada beloved Tracy will be
about what it's like to go on a long you
know home visit it takes some hours to
get there with this man who has a what
black tip in a karate is that what it's
called Brown tip just tell point good
point okay I mean so you know you think
guys got a karate tip or whatever that
he can you know walk up a mountain
without whining the whole way so then
I've got another series that are not so
much about Tracy
these aren't these aren't done yet but
they're inspired by Tracy you've heard
of his book house many of you have read
it I've got one called Hut it's coming
out and after that you I think Tracy won
a National Book Award for hometown I've
got slum coming out and some of you know
that the Haitian word for car is machine
the French word is watch you on the
Haitian where his machine and Tracy
writes so much about the road and the
cars and vehicles in his book you know
someone asked me this Tracy have an
obsession with you know roads and I said
no I'm not that I hope it's more of a
stool obsession but anyway so I'm just
gonna call the third book in that series
soul of a new machine
and I'm expecting to win a Pulitzer with
one of them anyway this has been a you
know this is a conversation I just want
to say a couple things about you know I
I just did this is this ought to make
you laugh again I've written a number of
books and I I just was asked to be on
fresh air so I just came from the studio
from doing fresh air and I said to the
the lady who was interviewing me you
know how come you never invited me to be
on fresh air before I was just joking
you know because everybody it's like
when is your book coming yeah it's the
same thing and and I was with some
friends who were winding me you know
it's time to come get over here to the
Longfellow hall which by the way is not
the place I would have read that passage
about identity politics baggage back
later for that and so they were pointing
at their watches and same time to move
and and so as the fresh air person
there's a producer and an interviewer
with signing off they said good luck on
your tour I'm not I'm not traveling
anywhere with him ever again
but one of the questions that she asked
which I found pertinent there were a
couple that were impertinent but I'll be
in Haiti when it comes out so I won't
hear it but in any case was she said
well well you know why did you know this
you must be uncomfortable you know this
must be a strange experience you know
and it is you know I seen your name on a
book but you if you didn't write it
that's a strange experience and and I
said it is a strange experience but I
can tell you why most of all and that is
because as I'm sure it's evident to many
of you here tonight the work that we do
whether in Haiti or Roxbury or Siberia
or Peru is teamwork you know and it's
about huge teams of people likes of like
Ophelia who actually is in the book a
lot and you know that's the the part
that's been a little bit difficult I've
already said all this to to Tracy in
recent ones is that you know I work as
part of a team and this is a book that
focuses a good deal on an individual
and the issue at hand I think and I
speak for my colleagues in Haiti and
here and Partners in Health and our
colleagues at the Brigham and our
colleagues at Harvard Medical School the
issue for us is really inequalities of
outcome in health care and the destitute
sick and that's what brought us all
together in this club that Tracy refers
to and that wasn't meant as a compliment
by the way when he said it was like a
club that it was meant a little bit as a
as a job but this is a club that we feel
should become a movement because anyone
as Tracy Kidder points out in his book
anyone can imagine themselves sick and
without a physician or a nurse or
someone looking after you without access
to medicine and that is the way the
world is today not just the world that
that is described in this book in detail
the six million people who will this
year died of AIDS tuberculosis and
malaria and you know there's no we have
all the tools we need to prevent all of
the deaths all six million of them but
there's no equity plan that it would
allow us to use them properly nor is
there any reason that someone who lives
in Roxbury should be bouncing in and out
of the hospital because they don't have
adequate care delivered in their home or
they can't fill a prescription and and
that's what the main issue is for those
of us that partners and help and and
again this is a big community a big club
that's Tracy says and it's a club that
we'd like to see become a movement
because we don't see any way forward
towards equity in health care if there
isn't a movement and that movement
cannot be local it has to be global and
it can't nor can it not pay attention to
local problems so I that's how I'd close
my comments and have a real conversation
with all of you is to say that we'd like
people to be part of this and that's why
I met Tracy in 1994 but that's why over
the last three years I've been traveling
with someone who likes to get to the the
gate two hours before the trip plane
leaves wasn't my fault
or I in Peru yeah wasn't me
so in any case thank you all for
supporting Partners in Health and and
thank thanks to Harvard bookstore for
making a making this event possible but
also this conversation possible but also
for being generous to partisan health at
in the holiday season we're very
grateful and we're dead serious about
about this movement idea and that's why
we've expanded our endeavors and we're
now working also and in with the Brigham
Women's Hospital and other facilities in
in this medical mecca to look harder at
health equities and to train a new
generation of doctors nurses there's
practitioners social workers other
people on the front lines community
health workers of course pharmacists
like my guests here to take health
inequalities seriously and we know of
course that medical people people who
are doing the work in the front lines
can't do it alone we have to have
support and and that requires the
support of the citizenry and the citizen
citizenry should be pushing people in
power and you know these are people I
don't know how they got well we didn't
really elect them but you know what I
mean
we almost elected them anyway they're in
power anyway so you know we're not
unconnected to them and our our own
movement we feel much more comfortable
working you know with people like you
with people in communities in Haiti and
Peru and Roxbury and in universities I
mean I sometimes my notion of who we
should be talking to us but if expansive
because I want to give a talk to the boy
scouts once and people have partners and
health accuse me of getting to talk to a
paramilitary organization they were
kidding anyway so we're hoping you'll
all join this movement and thank you
very much for letting me sit next to him
again thank you hey Paul I just want to
I want to give you one more conversation
from the past but this isn't between me
and Paul but between Paul and and a
wonderful man named Tom white and I just
to prove also that he Paul isn't the
only person in this book but and this is
just a little bit of the stuff about Tom
he was an older man I'm doing little Tom
wait is Passaic anyway just this little
certainly Haiti upset white he found the
road to college especially offensive he
did jogging along that damn road he'd
say he never traveled it without
thinking this would be so damn easy to
fix of course being the head of the
biggest construction firm Boston he
remembered his first view of kwashiorkor
there was a kid with red hair and a
bloated belly and I said right away put
in a feeding program here white found it
easy to imagine himself a Haitian a
child with big eyes and a memorable
smile encountered in a dirt Florida hut
made him feel like bringing over the
company bulldozers for Christ's sake
he'd say to Farmer or parallel phone paw
put a tin roof on and pour a concrete
floor I'll give you the money holy [ __ ]
when farmer was back in Boston doing his
internship at the Brigham white would
drive over at lunchtime and buy
sandwiches at the restaurant inside the
hospital he and farmer would eat them in
White's car one day white asked farmer
who looked pale as usual you eaten
enough oh I'm fine said farmer need any
money
no said farmer well maybe $40 white
happened to have a wad of hundred dollar
bills in his pocket he tossed one onto
into farmers lap you look hungry to me
saying this he felt impelled to reach in
his pocket again he tossed another
hundred the farmer please for God's
sakes eat he said and to emphasize the
point he gave farmer yet another hundred
farmer looked down the loot now I can
tell you what happened last night he'd
gone to the home of an AIDS patient whom
he had treated at the Brigham and found
out the man was about to be evicted I
signed to my check over to him jeez Paul
don't you think that's kind of
impractical farmer smiled well he said
God sent you today white often found
himself running errands in Boston for
projects and conning up things like
sinks and loading them into the trunk of
his Mercedes one load of sinks was for a
new clinic the first clinic turned out
to have been badly designed white paid
to have it rebuilt he did this quietly
not asking for credit not even a plaque
with his name on it
said farmer one time when they were
together in Boston white said you know
Paul sometimes I'd like to chuck it all
and work as a missionary with you in
Haiti farmer thought for a while then
said in your particular case that would
be a sin
well since this is a conversation I
would I will say I was an intern on that
particular event but there are plenty of
people and that that man happen to live
in Roxbury there are plenty of people
who do get evicted from their homes and
you know they often will tell you that's
because they have AIDS and I think
that's a perfectly legitimate way of
seeing it and you know that sounds again
in the way in the telling an unusual
occurrence it's not and since that time
Tom it was somewhat impractical for
impractical for me to sign over my check
to someone but since then we've come
across you know equally dramatic cases
and of people who are losing their
housing who have you know HIV and our
illegal entrance and you know we ended
up starting a project called PAC I don't
know if the director of pact is here
howdy-howdy buffer is it's a physician
who trained at the Brigham and she's
probably in clinic or visiting people in
their homes in Roxbury but this is one
of the projects that we're talking about
and you know if you think that it's if
it that it's rare that people are
evicted from their housing or that they
have housing insecurity as it's
sometimes called you know you you're
you're incorrect and it happens a lot
and a more practical way of doing it
than signing over one's check although
again that didn't put me at peril of
being anemic or hungry that's just how
Tom saw it but a more practical way of
doing it is to have housing security to
believe that housing food education
water and healthcare are rights or human
rights and then you don't have confusion
about what is the appropriate thing to
do for people who find themselves in
such perilous situations you know III
don't think part I don't think the part
isn't Harriet the Partners in Health is
a charity organization but more of a
social justice organization I don't
think there's anything wrong with
charity I think it's it's very laudable
at the same time I think it's safer for
people like us who you know are not
going to be pitched out in the street
and who are not going to go hungry
the problem with being an intern by the
way search that you're too busy to sit
down and eat but a better way to move
forward is to think about human rights
in a new way social and economic rights
that is the right to food the right to
health care the right to housing the
right to a job as is something that we
should support and for us at Partners in
Health the right to health care has been
a way in but we don't believe only in
the right to health care we actually do
believe in the right to housing security
and the right to you know this has gone
on and on and Haiti you know you have
people and you ask should you have the
right to teeth you know because people
don't have dental care they don't have
they lose their teeth young and then how
are they going to masticate their food
and we've gone through the long list of
things that we believe people ought to
have the right to and you know again
dental care is is one of them and over
the years we've uncovered all of these
strange situations right here on this
city and they're particularly disturbing
here because again you're right up
against such affluence and people can be
pitched out of their house with no
security and there are laws to prevent
that but they didn't really don't always
work for the for the most marginalized
and poor and again surely that's
something that could be fixed in this
city and that's what this project pact
is about you know there's a risk of
course that you know that story is a
true one you know and it happened again
you know signing over checks to took
patients without any untoward effect on
me I might add I never had housing
insecurity I always had a place to stay
now granted i I didn't often borrow
money from friends sorry about that but
you know without any great risk to to do
I mean a young position training could
easily sign over a check and and live to
tell the story you know what's gonna
happen you're gonna blow up or explode
you know it's not like it's a it's a
life-threatening act but it's just one
that doesn't come to mind very often and
I think the closer you get to people's
struggles with hunger with poverty with
housing insecurity with gender
inequality with racism the closer you
get to people's struggles you know if
you're a TB outreach worker or if you're
a physician you have this you have this
chance to get close to people it's
actually quite dignified I think you
know and I don't know how you know
lawyers or bankers do this maybe some of
you are lawyers or bankers could tell me
but for physicians it's really it's one
it's a great privilege to be able to you
know be around anybody and be welcome I
mean in Haiti of course that's been a
great privilege for me personally
because I've gotten so much out of out
of being there but I there I see friends
here from Cambridge hospital and they've
seen I can I can only imagine in fact
I'm one of the people who taught me
about the good idea of having a slush
fund for the this core sort of thing is
sitting right here and he's a
pediatrician at Cambridge Hospital I
won't get him in trouble but you know I
learned this also from other people who
have one foot in an institution like
Harvard and another foot in communities
that are disrupted by poverty inequality
I mentioned gender inequality racism you
know in Haiti the situation is very
different people you know they're wet
during the rainy season but housing
insecurity is a terrible thing anywhere
and again what we want is you know again
this is not to say anything negative
about charity because I think it gets a
bad name by some seminar room warriors
who you know we spend a lot of time
criticizing charity it'd be better than
what we have now I'd say but what we
really need is a movement for social
justice so these are regarded as rights
and I think you know I speak on behalf
of the people that partners helped and
saying this
so let's let them so we're done now it's
you yeah a-and I'm especially welcome
questions about antibiotics I'm glad to
answer those management of advanced HIV
disease multi drug-resistant
tuberculosis typhoid any of those are
fine with me our social economic right
hi my name is Kenneth coaster I actually
run the surgical clinic if only Blanc
and it happened to be in town with the
School of Public Health and one of the
great problems that we have which
touches upon something you said I'd like
to hear your thoughts is the absence of
profound social change to drive to drive
through cough you or a place like that
and see the fertile thousands and
realize that this problem is growing
exponentially and that we're really just
applying band-aids so what are your
thoughts on that
well first for those of you don't know
first first of all you're a surgeon
working in fund they belong and I would
like to say I think that's admirable and
and I said yesterday to my medical
students for their first year medical
students and this is a class of social
medicine and I was of the opinion that
they shouldn't have to apologize for
being physicians and or nurses or nurse
practitioners or people who are doing
band-aid work and so fun they belong for
those of you don't know as part of Haiti
and cowboy is an urban slum but if you
want my thoughts on the matter
I'll give them to you don't stop doing
surgeries for free you probably pay your
own own airfare too
don't stop doing that we need people to
help do that in in Haiti people have
surgical disease they're dying of
untreated surgical disease we have a
very busy surgical clinic in konjam we
don't charge people for those services
that's what we mean by moving resources
down
very steep gradient I'm in equality but
that's not my real answer my first thing
is to say keep it up don't give up my
real answer is why is it that the United
States is blocking humanitarian and
development assistance to the poorest
country in this hemisphere why are they
blocking why is the Bush administration
using political influence to make sure
that fundamental change doesn't happen
why are we blocking a water loan an
educational loan a Road and
transportation loan and a health sector
reform loan that are already approved by
the Haitian Parliament the Haitian
executive branch and the inter-american
Development Bank and when I bring that
up then suddenly I'm not very popular
anymore you know when I bring that up in
the United States say you know write
your Congress people tell them you don't
want the whims of Washington to decide
whether or not the richest country in
the hemisphere is going to block
assistance to the poorest hemisphere
country in the hemisphere and again you
know Barbara Lee said it she's the
leader of the Congressional Black Caucus
Chris Dodd said it he's a senator from
Connecticut but when I say it you know
it suddenly you know you go from
humanitarian doctor to you know
political radical or something well it
happens to be the case that these loans
approved in 1998 have not they're still
in Washington and and one month ago
Haiti the Republic of Haiti the second
oldest country in the hemisphere ours
being the oldest one mine anyway Utes
yours - I suggest by your accent and
bearing just emptied 92% of its national
reserves to pay off the odious debt
accrued by you know the Duvalier's and
others who had taken out loans from this
bank no problem so again the reason
there are band-aid there the reason that
we're not seeing fundamental change is
that are very powerful country is
blocking it and has been doing it and
I'll give you the history if you want
I'm sure everyone's eyes will roll but
we did it in the 19th century when we
refused to recognise Haiti's sovereign
status until 1865 because we had slaves
in this country so senators from South
Carolina got up to the Senate floor and
said our very the security of our very
country forbids us or even from even
mentioning Haiti exists that went on
till 1865 then in the late 18th cent
19th century we sent gunboats in and
then finally in 1915 we invaded Haiti
and were there 20 years as a military
occupation established the modern
Haitian army which has caused me and my
patients a lot of trouble and that was
established by an act of US Congress
sign right here in Washington and it
gave me to bring this stuff off you
don't get invited to the Sun Valley's
Writers Conference and it's important
that's why I'd say keep up the surgery
but just know and I'm gonna keep up my
day job too but just know if everyone
could put a little bit of time into
exploring these these bizarre and unfair
and I frankly don't think they reflect
the American people's will I'd like to
think that I mean the Americans I know
are great people so I can't imagine
cutting off water to the thirsty or
denying education to children who need
it most
or trying to make those roads remain in
the condition they are I feel like I
should say to Tracy I feel there's a
thing that happens in Tracy's book
everybody is gonna see that you know I
but I didn't see it that's the thing
that bothered me you know I thought he
was really enjoying my company enormous
Lee and thought I was hilarious and then
I read the book and then I find out he
has a number of serious gripes with me
anyway that's that's a exempt anyway
what I'm saying is I think that I don't
really don't think that Tracy Kidder
believed me when I told him a story
about the block aid I mean I didn't say
look me in the eye Tracy Kidder and tell
me you believe everything anything he
did and so he looked into it himself and
I have i misstated anything nope
actually not I don't think I mean you
know one could one could spend a
lifetime trying to figure out trying to
find out the reasons why Washington is
doing this has been doing this continues
to do this but I think it's pretty clear
that we don't like
I don't think that the United States in
Latin America or the current
administration really likes popular
democracy thank you stop right there
that's only that's a major victory I
think I can say that publicly well this
particular set of loans has approved
some of the delays happened in Haiti
it's really been in the last two years
that the spigot system have been stopped
mostly by Washington and you know it's
illegal okay and I know people are
interested I'll be glad to give you an
information or our tracy has this is
this is my favorite part of the story
Tracy the Pulitzer Prize winning author
has a piece coming out in the nation
which is read by you know my mother and
her friends it's too radical for your
mom but it's coming out next week on
this topic and I hope I hope people will
read it but if you want details folks at
Partners in Health we'll be glad to give
you the details on it you know another
friend from Haiti my sister Nancy dohsa
and the others here and she can you know
keep you tell you about it - she's been
very involved in trying to get this
assistance unblocked but it's illegal
you know it's a it's a says in the
Charter I never was interested in this
stuff because we don't get we don't get
support like that we get support from
Harvard bookstore yeah
but it says in the charter of this Bank
that pollute politics will not be used
to mess up you know walk clean water
planets so they seem to follow that very
happily when the new values for running
the show for 30 years it's only now that
the Haitians have elected people that
Washington doesn't like their first
elections were in in just just there
recently coming out of 180 years of not
having a popular democracy that's when
the screws tightened it's amazing how
profound it's been we went from being
you know in 1986 the military took over
I was there then and in the 18 months
after February 1986 when the military
started running Haiti and I'll shut up
now
we passed 220 million dollars through
the Haitian government you know and now
we're saying sorry we can't we can't
even let other institutions treat Haiti
like a normal
of the international community if there
such a thing not that I care
this perfect segue I'm Donna now if I
take delegations to Cuba and Haiti
through witness for peace and pastors
for peace and Paul I know you and I both
care deeply about Cuba and the way it
treats those people and I'm wondering if
you could compare and contrast health
care in Cuba and Haiti um can I have an
hour now just two minutes I mean you
know these are two neighboring islands
and actually a friend of mine who's here
actually got me to write a little bit
about this seven years ago and I just it
was heartbreaking because these islands
are you know 90 miles apart and you know
one has the most doctors per capita in
the hemisphere one has the least one has
the highest maternal mortality one has
the lowest one has the highest infant
mortality one has it lowest and and it
goes on and on and and and it you know
again one of the arguments that's
mentioned I didn't know it was an
argument till I read the book which was
actually quite recently but you know I
I'm you know I'm interested in health
care you know everybody wants to focus
on something I think and I focused on
infectious diseases but you know they
these are two countries with the same
topography the same geography and and
and you know interestingly a few hundred
years ago they had similar histories
they were slave colonies both of them
and then their histories diverged
radically and of course therein lies the
rub but you know Cuba has really
eradicated the infectious disease
epidemics that were battling in Haiti
and you know as has been pointed out by
my colleague these are band-aid
interventions and we're not embarrassed
about them and I certainly hope you
won't be embarrassed I think it's a
great it's a noble thing to donate your
services to work for people who can't
and never will pay you I think that's a
great thing but you know in order for
there to be significant decrease in the
in the epidemics that we're dealing with
in Haiti there would have to be very
profound changes and and you know I
mentioned the ones that concern
Americans directly because you know we
shouldn't be blocking you know water
assist
- hey I know that you all probably saw
this everybody you all got the water
poverty index that came out a few months
ago Ryder last year 147 yeah Haiti was
147 out of 147 countries surveyed and
this is the country that we're blocking
water assistance to which they're paying
for I mean we're not letting them access
credit like another country so I think
in conversations one is supposed to
disagree but I don't disagree about this
I went to Haiti to do research on this
story and went to I thought I should I
took a look at the potable water
supplies just in port-au-prince and
watched people bathing in sewer water
and ultimately my little tour ended up
at the at the morgue where which was
overfilled that day and you know you
could bet that a lot of the infants
there who had died because of dirty
water little girls with bows in their
hair still in their dresses it was
actually the question is more to do with
yearbook they actually haven't read mr.
caters all right all right I planned it
that's got to be a first pathologies of
power so a few minutes ago you you just
tossed out the phrase seminar room
warriors and I was wondering if you
think that academics have any can have
any role in bringing about justice you
know professor here I mean there are
other professors in this room full
professors and sitting right here
there's a there's a professor of Health
and Human Rights in this room there's a
professor of Latin American history and
that and let me just finish with my
thought and then you can go back but I I
learned you know I'm not in there
there's a former Surgeon General in this
room there is a former dean of Harvard
School of Public Health in this room and
you know if I just mentioned I won't
mention their names but the former
Surgeon General in the room is the
person who created headstart and that
was a movement of about a hundred
million dollars from rich America to
poor America and I happen to know that
his own daughter criticized him for
working in Washington or said dad you
know why are you like you know going to
washing this was not even during a
Republican administration my dad and he
said you know if I can move one hundred
million dollars from rich America to
poor America and I'm gonna do it and you
know and the Dean of the School of
Public Health in this room wrote a book
about the American healthcare system and
which ended up getting called in one of
its version paperback I think no room in
the lifeboat and it's a critique of
market-based medicine so you know that's
sort of the pillar you know and then or
let me get back to the professor of
Latin American history the professor of
Latin American history has written
scorching scorching commentary about US
policy in Latin America but it's it's
scholarly work it's well documented it's
scorching because our behave
have been our behavior and policies have
been scorching but he tells it like it
is in fact I was just recently we asked
him to be a respondent and he even has
one of those fancy you know named chairs
and all we asked him to be a respondent
we're talking about Guatemala about the
genocide 'el spree of the army there and
he he didn't speak long but he talked
about that great flesh and bone chipper
up in Washington you know when people
can talk like that and they can be
professors or then I didn't mention the
Health and Human Rights professor who
does just that
only that's what he does that's what his
chair is about talking about not just
symbol and political rights but also
social and economic rights and how the
right to healthcare is important and if
you're a student here and some of my
students are here there's they're some
of my former students now colleagues are
here I would say don't write off you
know don't write off the institutions of
power and privilege in which you are
shaped and formed I mean I I these
connection
I was teasing Tracy about in the Paris
Airport I think I learned how to do that
in a scholarly manner right here and
this university from professors and I'm
very grateful for it
I I don't know and that's why I still
teach here and that's why as I mentioned
we're expanding some of our efforts in
the university with undergraduates as
well with medical students with
residents and fellows because you know
if you want to make a movement I mean
that sounds you know perhaps grandiose
and there's no small amount of
grandiosity in the comments I did I
really say all those things in any case
I think that academics you know have a
very important role to play and what
they should be doing is telling the
truth because they have access to truth
I guess an extension of my question is
about a certain discipline I just that
um I guess economics I mean it's an
incredibly powerful one but one in which
like the standards of scholar legitimacy
are very much it adds with them I guess
moral arguments you know I think that
they're underpinned by ideological
arguments but you know the economists
are not willing to agree they call it
science some some called the dismal
science I might add quite
inappropriately I don't know a lot about
economics but the idea that economics is
currently practiced is ideology free is
absurd to me I think it's ridiculous so
even you know basic science is still
sculpted by social factors you know
granted we don't question chemists
darkly about their motives but at the
same time you know they're a lot closer
to having a legitimate claim to being a
you know value-free you know realm of
inquiry I don't think economics meets
that any more than any of the other
social sciences so do you think it's
necessary to have like to keep like a
commitment to a specific community or
whatever in order to keep oneself sort
of responsible and honest as an academic
I think that that must very enormous Lee
from person to person you know I've met
people like Tom White who without ever
you know doesn't have to go to El
Salvador to spend a lot of his time and
even money you know campaigning for
justice after you know you know there
was a war a terrible civil war in El
Salvador again financed inexplicably by
a lot of US dollars tax money and you
know Tom white is a you know he's 83 now
he didn't need to go to El Salvador you
know and so there so to must there be
academics who can actually maintain
great integrity without ever visiting
the places that they study the the
eminent historian of Latin America
studies usually studies a prior and he
can't go into a time machine to go back
to the time he studies and you know so
III think it must vary I personally if
that's what you're getting at I need to
be able to spend part of my time in
afflicted communities but I don't regard
that as as I regard that as inferior
morally inferior because it's surely the
most impressive people are the ones who
act purely on principle and are engaged
in telling the truth just because that's
what you should do and they don't need
to see suffering up those that's a
really admirable kind of activism to me
I admire that more than than my own kind
of activism they think it's just I'm
hearing about thank you well I'm just
getting warmed up notice how am I
talking to no no fine it's gonna told me
a couple years ago I'm talking about my
questions for Paul I was I was hoping
you could share some of your wisdom on
your personal commitment to the issues
of health care inequality it's beyond
professional it's obvious and I just
like to hear how how you put that as a
priority and if it's been difficult for
you well I you know you you know people
this is something I I don't believe you
know there's a current in and it's very
strong in academic circles now to talk
about personal experience as the
legitimating factor for your engagement
with a problem I I think again that is
to me inferior to be
being engaged on principle and and
that's why I rather unfortunately made
some of those comments in front of him
but my guard was down I've been hanging
around with him for a long time you know
and I told you a minim in 1994 but you
know so and what I'm really saying is
it's not because I didn't I grew up
without health insurance which as far as
I know it's true
I mean in other words I think I didn't
and and and also it's you know as far as
I can remember when I went to get my
shots for school and stuff I went to the
public clinic for free free shots and
things like that and well I broke my arm
playing football with my brothers you'd
think I one of them's a pro wrestler so
why would I ever do something stupid
like that
the Haitians look at my brother and they
say same mother same father and he's the
smaller of the two so the reason that I
was playing football is because my
father forced me to play football and
then I broke my arm I mean and so what
did my father say unsportsmanlike
conduct to me not to my brother and then
he told me I'll set it for you anyway
make a long story short I said no dad
you will not you will take me to the
emergency room what a bet worked out
better probably if my father done it
because the guy who saw me was under the
influence of alcohol anyway so but but I
don't and I still have a crooked owner
but that's not why I believe so what I'm
saying is I don't think that's why any
of us should get involved in this
because what if what if you never had
what if you always had the best in
medical care shouldn't you still be it
shouldn't you have even more reason to
be involved and I think and I've made
this argument before and in fact in a
lot in the book that was just mentioned
and was reviewed by a friend of mine
who's here tonight that getting involved
in healthcare inequality is a way of
bringing a lot of other people on board
because again anybody could imagine
either being sick themselves or having a
loved one be sick and then knowing that
most people in the world do not have
access to good medical care I mean that
is something that can Pete you can you
don't have to be a doctor or nurse or
nurse practitioner or a social worker to
think all you have to do is be part of a
family you know to know someone who's
been sick and and almost died or
did die and then when you start meeting
people who died because they had no
access to care and of course that's easy
to do and I mentioned that you don't
have to travel you don't have to go to
Haiti to find that but you can find
people in you know right right you know
right hard against the medical mecca
where I get to teach and see patients so
I think that deep personal commitment is
the natural the natural obligation of
physicians and I've told this to my
students and friends who are probably
sick of hearing it actually they're not
sick of hearing it or they wouldn't be
here but I think that it's part it's
something for everybody to be interested
in you know health and equality Martin
Luther King said of all the forms of
inequality inequality in health is the
most shocking and I think he might he
was on to something and it's just a way
of bringing more and more people into
the human rights struggle because that's
the subtext of hate trace traces book to
you know it's about the right to not be
hungry and the right to not be wet when
it's raining outside and then the right
to to have access to care when you're
sick thank you very much this is a
question for mr. Kidder I read the book
and I was very moved by it and I was
wondering what your how being in Haiti
for all that time and traveling with
Paul how that may have changed your life
well I don't fully agree with Paul least
about experience I mean I when I first
saw Haiti in 1994 era Steve had just
been restored to power and I I was I
thought I was pretty worldly wise I've
been a soldier in Vietnam I had never
seen anything like it
I'd never imagined anything quite like
it it was so awful and when I you know I
met Paul there and I and I saw him again
in Boston and I began to get the sense
of the lineaments of his of his life and
I was kind of bobbing and weaving and
shucking and jiving and trying to find a
way to accommodate John I shut up
sorry no you know trying to accommodate
Haiti into my philosophy and I you know
I what I what I sort of came up with I
was doing an article for The New Yorker
and I what I sort of came up with seems
really unsatisfactory to me now
was a sort of notion I kind of bought
into the pessimism of the soldiers I've
been hanging out with whom I like very
much by the way the American soldiers
which was and I didn't see really see
poll actually see Paul again for six
years I and I think I was a little
afraid to I was afraid he would disturb
my peace which had proceeded to do yes
might add that's true in an infinite
number of ways now just but mostly he's
getting started what I what I what I
came away realizing was that it wasn't
that you know wasn't satisfactory to
there was no way to put a Haiti aside
out of your mind - really there's no way
it's a catastrophe and it and it's got
to be fixed
no and so I guess I mean it's as simple
it's really just as simple as that I
just feel that it's got to be fixed and
I'm quite willing at might one of my
favorite writers Graham Greene once said
I have never minded being used but that
in quotes for a cause that I believe in
I don't I don't think that I would sleep
well at night if if is I mean Asante
stopped functioning and I don't think
can sleep entirely well knowing just how
many people are dying unnecessarily in
Haiti and what misery they and they live
in and so you know that's a change I'm
not I'm not prepared to go down and work
with Paul in Haiti because I went simply
getting away one thing and besides he'd
be so busy taking care of my GI system
see his TB patients but uh but I I hope
to contribute you know whatever ways I
can I just would like to say one thing
first of all I think there was a great
question and I'm glad I didn't have to
ask it but you know Haiti is a
catastrophe that needs to be fixed but
they keep trying to fix it they tried in
1791 to 1804 and we helped block it they
tried a hundred and eighty years later
in 1990 you know and we didn't help and
we may have tried to block it again
that'll be the way to the historians
getting back to our the question from me
I am assuming you may be a student here
but well we may have been obstructing
there I think there's a lot of
likelihood that we actively campaigned
against popular democracy I think we
have you know a lot of a lot of
information and so you know it's it's
got to be fixed but we've got to stop
you know sabotaging the popular movement
you know there's this expression you
know give them you know teach a man to
fit or give a man to fish feed him for
the day this is not gender sensitive see
I can I want to kill him for using that
passage but but give a teacher man a
fish you feed him for life but you see
that is not what happened here
what happened is there we helped destroy
the fleet and the fishing boats and
pollute the waters and that's the
history that people don't want to hear
about the history of how you know a
catastrophe unfolded over time and the
ways in which the powerful were so
tightly linked to the disempowered you
know from slavery it's late you know
slave owner to slave all the way to the
current time again this is the part that
no one wants you to write about and talk
about
but it's what underpins the catastrophe
which is absolutely soluble this is not
an insuperable problem that the problems
that we see in Haiti the political
problems the health problems of social
problems these are not insuperable
problems Hey
want to fix them you know and that's why
they keep trying and they were the ones
who led the way they were the human
rights nation you know in 1791 when and
when they started the Haitian Revolution
the US Revolution was not against
slavery you know and the Haitian
Revolution was and it was the first one
and you know it's sort of like they came
here 200 years too early you would have
thought if it happened during the
Enlightenment it would have been a good
time
it wasn't everybody else just punished
them for decades and decades and decades
and I think that's where you know that's
why I'm here I'm leaving tomorrow so I'm
not going on tour as I said but it's
people like us the citizenry who can
make a difference I believe maybe that's
just psychopathology but you know I
think that we have a say we are not you
know we are not peasants living in
poverty they've already made the smart
choices they've already risked their
lives to go vote and to make their will
clear they've already done all that and
then what have they had of not only a
lack of cooperation but sabotage of
their popular movement and you know I
think that's got to stop and and we're
the were the people who got to make it
stop
we have to make it stop thank you
mountains beyond mountains healing the
world the quest of dr. Paul Farmer is
published by Random House to learn more
go to Random House dot-com